hello everyone and welcome to a game
that i consider an absolute privilege to
share with everyone uh it was played a
few days ago in round seven of the
listing and open in netherlands uh
between uh these two gentlemen between
uh thomas bertsen and shiraz royal
thomas being an international master
character being a feeder master also the
the youngest ever feeding master uh in
england and uh we've already checked out
one game uh by bertson uh he faced
magnus carlsen it was it was a bullet
game uh in the uh that was played on
leeches so if you haven't seen that also
do check it out i will put a link to it
in description below if you want to see
but what made me actually even um
you know uh
dig up this game is that uh howard
stanton uh posted it on twitter not the
real howard staunton that would be
really weird uh but uh someone um
sort of uh
honoring him with the account and
when there's a great game being played
like this um he will of course uh uh
posted on twitter and i'm very glad that
he did and i'm very glad a lot of you
guys have tagged me on it's uh i saw it
it uh catches my attention even though
i'm pretty sure i i would have seen it a
game like this would not escape
uh you know uh my attention
uh so let's dive straight into it and
then we are going to uh we'll uh i don't
know i i don't know i don't want to
spoil it to you but uh you guys will be
amazed by this one uh so betsy has the
white piece and he opens with e4 as we
have already announced that the evans
gambit will be on the board so e5 knight
to f3 knights to c6 and the bishop to c4
we have bishop to c5 the joko piano and
now the strongest move in the position
want to be for the evans gambit is on
the board and black counters the gambit
by accepting it as that is the best way
to do it so bishop captures pawn to c3
and the bishop to a5 and now just d4 and
if you've seen my uh
sort of a tutorial video on how to play
the evidence gambit we have covered many
of the lines this line is included and i
will also include a link to that in the
description below if you are hearing
about the evidence gambit for the first
time do check it out as it um uh well
will lead you uh you know through some
uh elementary lines so you can start
playing it with white but here comes a
line that i have not covered uh and it's
an extremely rare move i've seen it
played in similar positions i've seen it
played in in the kings game but i've
seen it played
in uh well basically in
some open games where the bishop is
developed on c4 controlling this
diagonal and that is pawn to b5 and the
idea is you want to give back one pawn
at uh make this light square bishop not
as powerful as it usually is so it's not
a new movie it has been played before
but only in a handful of games we have
bishop captures on b5
and now knight captures on d4 the c3
pawn is pin so you can't capture back
and also now the bishop is hanging so
you kind of have to play knight captures
on d4 so knight captures e captures and
here yeah there isn't just castles and
now uh white uh or rather black should
consider uh just knight to knight 37 in
castles but he goes for the bald d
captures on c3 grabbing the pawn and now
he has a pass pawn at c3 but will he be
able to uh hang on to it
that's uh the real question and there is
only one move in the position that is
good for white and the one that uh a lot
of people might miss
because it kind of wastes the tempo but
it is bishop to c4 and you don't really
waste the tempo because black also
wasted a tempo grabbing the pawn here so
now the bishop is on the diagonal where
it belongs attacking the weak f7 square
and it's very hard to continue the game
here for black yeah for example if you
go for the knight f6 which is a natural
way to develop your piece is just e5 and
there's no good square for the knight if
you go back with knights to g8 then just
queen f3 threatens checkmate and also
the rook on a8 is hanging and if you try
the well the idea that usually works
when e5 is played sort of d5 attacking
the bishop just e captures and after d
captures on c4 there's f captures on g7
you don't have time to trade because
this comes with checks so rook g8 now
queen a4 check picks up the bishop and
the black just gets obliterated
so that's one way to do it and also if
you try something like d6 to prevent e5
then the immediate queen h5 also wins
just threatening checkmate and the
bishop is now hanging so bla that's why
i said it was a really really bold move
uh capturing on c3 but black kind of
makes it work knight to the e7 uh by
shraz
and now uh white plays rook to e i'm
just kidding of course white played
bishop captures on f7 we do not want to
see the black king castling and also
it's not really a peace sacrifice since
the bishop on a5 also will hang so king
captures on f7 queen to h5 check king to
g8 and now queen captures on a5 we have
h6 and now black is saying all right i'm
up material if we count the pawns i have
six pawns white has only five pawns and
if i can play king h7 and bring my rook
into the game i should be okay and if
especially if the pawn can survive but
it's very unlikely it's already attacked
twice so
basically it's going to be equal
material knight captures on c3 king to
h7 and now bishop to a3 we have d6 and
now rook 8 to d1 uh we have bishop to b7
fiance in the bishop uh pawn to f4 and
now rook to ea preparing to move the
knight and put pressure on this e4 pawn
and now bishop back to b2 as the bishop
really does belong on this diagonal and
some rook lifts in the future might be
possible going for that g7 pawn so queen
d7 and now rook to d3 we have knights to
g8 uh and now we have pawn to e5 makes
sense as of course the pawn cannot be
captured and also you take away the f6
square for the knight but not just
knight back to e7 as the f5 square was
weakened so knight to b5 putting
pressure on c7 knight captures on c7
would be excellent for white and here we
have queen to c6 and now i'm sure you
guys are wondering what happens if
knight captures on c7 will of course
queen captures on g2 checkmate i was
only kidding i know none of you missed
that so here rook the g3 defending
checkmate uh and um
there you you could also play something
else for example uh you could play
something like rook to d to defend the
checkmate this way and this is in fact
the stronger move
but rook to g3 is definitely in the
style of old masters as both of them uh
sort of uh got into the mood and
especially when uh shiraz played that b5
move uh
of course they
they both agreed that they will play
this in the style of old masters and no
pawns
will be counted so here knight to f5
attacking the rook but bersen just says
what about knight to f5 i have a knight
to d4 now now you can't capture my rook
because i would capture your queen so
here at knight captures on d4 this this
is pretty much forced uh bishop captures
on d4 and now d captures an e5 we have
bishop captures now attacking the g7
pawn and the rook to e7
really finding all the right moves and
the defending uh
truly valiantly we have queen to a3 now
attacking the rook and now comes rook to
d7 getting the rook out of the way uh
here there is a very tricky move for
black and that is queen to b6 check now
you might be wondering what's the point
of this you know we never just want to
deliver a check just just because we can
but here point is after queen to b6
check and king to h1 there is queen to
a6
and now with white characters you just
check made white with queen captures on
f1 so white really has to decide whether
to trade queens or to move the queen
back with queen to c1 uh which of course
uh uh
kicks the queen away from uh from from
from such an active square uh so you
always have to look for such ideas so
you know when your opponent has not
played king to h one and the f four four
pawn has been moved you have to look for
resources like this so okay rook to d7
uh we have h3 now so you don't have to
worry about any background issues in the
future and now rook the g8 adding
another defender so now this rook can
move
rook to c1 chasing away the queen and
now comes queen to e4 uh also possible
is just queen to a6 um not to trade the
queens but uh even though it's uh the
best that the engine recommends for
example captures captures uh and now
rook to a3 attacks the bishop uh black
will just lose a lot of material you're
going to lose this pawn you're going to
lose this pawn and it would be a miracle
if black holds this yes the bishops are
of opposite color but if you if you can
trade a rook maybe you can hold it but
if not very unlikely so okay queen to e4
black of course wants to keep the queens
on the board and now rook captures on c7
rook captures and the bishop captures
and here uh royal finds g5 and it's a
spectacular move that can only be bested
if
bertson finds that one a particular move
the only move that wins the game so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
win this position for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
brilliant brilliant maneuver and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course bishop to e5 we can
even do it in slow motion as it's so
strong look at this bishop to e5 uh what
bishop to e5 does is that it takes away
the e7 square
from the black wing so you are no longer
covering the e7 square so queen to e7
check becomes possible and also you take
away the g7 square for the from the rook
so black cannot shield the king with
king to g7 so how do you stop queen e7
check uh there's just no good way to do
it here rook to e8 is played this does
prevent queen e7 but now queen captures
on a7 grabbing the pawn now finally
white is up material now white is up two
pawns and now even the the a4 pawn can
start marching forward and the real
question is why doesn't g captures on f4
work and of course if you are wondering
about that it is rook to g7 check and
now you can see that there really isn't
all that much you can do after king to
h8 um
it's just game over uh but uh you still
have to play it very carefully and
that's why i decided to show it because
it seems like you can just move the rook
anywhere and it's gonna be winning for
you for example you can capture this
open up a discovery and it's winning uh
but after rook captures on e5 you're
still going to have to work for your
meal and especially if you try something
like rook to e7 check to pick up the
rook uh there's the very nasty king g8
and now after rook capture 78 check now
you can play king to f7 and all of a
sudden uh the win it no longer exists
because checkmate is being threatened
and also the rook is hanging so uh
you you you would have to be very very
careful here uh but the point is the the
real idea after g captures on f4 is rook
to g7 king to h8 and now bishop to d4
this is the star move and it seems that
the the uh the uh
white's dark square bishop is truly the
star player of this game now there is no
defense whatever you play it's
you just get destroyed because there are
no tactics
that existed in the previous line uh so
uh uh instead after queen captures on a7
we have rook to e7 guarding the bishop
but now queen the b8 check going after
queen to h8 and now there is no saving
this position for black rook to d7 was
played uh trying to get that to rook
into the attack but it is much too late
queen to h8 with check king to g6 queen
to g8 to check king to f5 or h5 doesn't
really matter ends the same and now rook
captures and g5 the brilliant brilliant
finish and he was in this position on
move 36 uh that uh schroeder resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here i know it seems like more
moves have been played than it usually
does when we check out an evan's gambit
game because we cover a lot of really
cool lines so you know
you get this illusion that the game
lasted longer but in fact it was only 36
moves and here you resign because after
h captures and g5 you of course don't
play queen captures on g5 because if you
do this then king e6 and now black
escapes you are just down a rook
but after this capture just g4 and this
is now checkmated there is no square for
the black king so truly truly wonderful
queen covering g6 and e6 bishop covering
f6 that's it the king is completely
boxed in and that's a game
uh so yeah after looking after sanji
five uh shatsuroa resigned the game and
a brilliant brilliant victory uh for
thomas bertsen
in round seven of this wonderful
wonderful tournament and it almost
got him all the way up to the top uh he
ended in in shared second place with
seven out of nine uh the tournament was
won by harsha baratakoti with eight out
of nine which is truly truly spectacular
and shiraz royale i believe finished on
six and a half out of nine which is also
uh uh truly incredible if he had won
that game he would have seven and a half
out of nine uh which
uh would be incredible he would he would
have a you know a sold second place uh
uh behind harsha and uh well he he was
incredibly close but uh you know this
was this was truly a spectacular game so
i'm very very glad they played it and to
play such a game of course it takes two
uh if uh if uh shiraz royal did not play
such a bold uh
move six with pawn to b5 we wouldn't
have such a rich game to enjoy so also
kudos to him for you know continuing the
game in the style of old masters even in
2022.
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank gabriel
rodriguez evan sterling john austin
andrei schrader and dixit varma for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and if you haven't do check out
bertson's game against magnus first link
in the description below see you soon